الاجواء لا توصف اطلق العنان لفرحه مستحقه
فرحه الوصول لاول مره لنصف النهائي لاول
مره كمنتخب عربي كمنتخب افريقي الى نصف
النهائي وبالتالي هذه الفرحه هي فرحه
مستحقه وانتظرت لاكثر من ثلاثه عقود كل
الجماهير التي اا
التقيناها كانت كان شعارها واحد فقط هو
الفوز والتقدم
والمضيء بعيدا في هذه في هذه المسابقه
ربما فرحت اليوم فرحه مباراه البرتغال
تفتحوا الباب من اجل فرحه اخرى الجماهير
بدات تطمع في الوصول حتى الى ابعد من هذه
المباراه هذه المباراه
او كبيره كبيره
مقاومه تاريخيه عشناها على اعصابنا على
الرغم الاصابات على الرغم من المباراه
القادمه اما انجلترا او فرنسا همم فرنسا
ان شاء الله
مع الاوروبيين وعندنا تاريخ مع فرنسا وزي
ما تغلبنا عليه بلجيكا وعذبنا كرواتيا
واخرجنا همم اخرجنا البرتغال ان شاء الله
هنخرج فرنسا المباراه القادمه محتمل بين
بين فرنسا او انجلترا
ان شاء الله شكرا للقناه العربيه شكرا على
التقطيع هنيئا للشعب المغربي ملك
الى النهايه ان شاء الله وانت يعني
المباراه القادمه يا فرنسا
حيث فرنسا
المباراه القادمه
المنتخب سيواجه اما انجلترا او فرنسا ماذا
تتمنى انت كمغربي مغربي كم مغربي ان شاء
الله فرنسا ان شاء الله